but you know my setup right now is like
I think to myself okay there are there
are two big aspects of my life and
they're they're measurable in very
different ways so in my personal life my
whole job is to realize kind of two
things the first is and this and the
coronavirus has been amazing for me
which is I'm powerless I'm just as
powerless as the fruit vendor and just
as powerless as the President of the
United States we are all equal in a
moment like this and that is incredibly
humbling to internalize okay we're all
equal but it doesn't mean that we're
irrelevant
so being powerless is one thing but we
are very relevant
I am relevant to my friends and my
family and I have a responsibility to be
really functional for them in moments
like this so it's about maintaining
clarity making sure I realize how lucky
I am being appreciative staying healthy
helping my family talking to my friends
making sure that when I see them in
moments were there you know when you're
cooped up for a month it's tough it's
helping them so so I've realized that
measuring myself in my personal life is
about those things